die spritpreise in deutschland die sind
viel zu hoch und die politik die muss
jetzt reagieren die bürger müssen
entlastet werden die müssen an der
zapfsäule merken dass die spritkosten
wieder runter gehen die beste
möglichkeit um die spritkosten zu senken
während steuerentlastung die könnte man
schnell durchführen und man könnte sie
vor allem unbürokratisch durchführen
statt jetzt steuersenkungen vorzunehmen
verheddert sich die ampel koalition aber
im klein klein und die eine hand weiß
nicht was die andere hand will christian
lindner kommt mit bürokratischen
vorschlägen will eine zettelwirtschaft
an tankstellen etablieren am selben tag
widerspricht ihm aber robert habeck und
ich fordere deswegen die ampel koalition
auf hören sie auf mit politischen
klein-klein hören sie auf mit dem
parteipolitischen hickhack wir brauchen
jetzt steuersenkungen wir brauchen jetzt
die spritpreis bremse sehr richtig
halte ich für eine forderung der mann
gar nicht widersprechen kann ich glaube
auch dass das kommen wird die frage ist
wie es kommen wird und wie lange man
noch sinnlose schleifen dreht bevor man
sich auf eine lösung verständigt hat die
stimme ihrer meinung über die gutscheine
völlig zu
es gibt ja diverse steuer ansätze bei
der mehrwertsteuer sagt lindner kann er
nicht weil europäisches recht dem
widerspricht könnte aber sein dass das
doch zugelassen wird von europäischen
union ins spiel da gar keine rolle es
gibt noch die mineralölsteuer man kann
an diversen punkten ansetzen um die
steuer senken und das muss schnellstens
passieren herr möller wenn sie uns hier
so reden hören über den spritpreis das
ist ein problem was uns hier in
deutschland sehr sehr stark beschäftigt
die steigenden preise gibt es denn auch
ein alltägliches problem ein
gravierendes problem was in amerika
stattfinden blick auf putin was die
amerikaner beschäftigt mit ihrer eigenen
wirtschaft
na ja sicher auch das ist klar das wird
hier sieht man auf fox cnn dass man über
alle sender informiert auch der die
reden von beiden
teilweise auch zum beispiel jetzt von
ski der ja auch jetzt
ein tag zuvor bei uns gesprochen hat zum
us-kongress hat stehende ovation kommen
die amerikaner haben auch danach
diskutiert wie gesagt die haben mich wie
versucht wie ist jetzt ja heute von
normal ich habe es noch nicht gesehen
was da im deutschen bundestag passiert
ist gleich mit glückwünsche und gleich
das thema das erinnert mich etwas um die
vorhin schon sagte man bild immer
schnell so ein thema schnell loswerden
und dann wieder weiter gehen was wir
hier viel segen ist ehemaliger bunten
der präsident trump kann man nur sagen
gott sei dank dass der im moment nicht
dabei ist weil der wirt der nato und
deutschland und der ukraine auch nicht
als zu grosse hilfe leisten
wie ich schon hier die großen experten
sagten steht auch kurz davor dass er
wahrscheinlich damit muss man rechnen in
zwei drei jahren wieder zurück ist und
seine er mehr abmachen bewundert ist
ebenfalls china russland und nordkorea
aber dort die diktatoren eben ganz
einfach diktatoren sind ohne
menschenrechte aber das ist auch
anrufe ein
das ist immer wieder was wir hier auch
erleben trump kommt rein spricht man man
sich natürlich bilder er natürlich schon
damals gesagt dass die deutschen im
budget vom militär erhöhen sollen dass
sie nicht von diskurs nicht so abhängig
von deutschland machen von russland
machen sollen in puncto öl und gas line
und und und und das ist eben halt trifft
natürlich jetzt auch genau auf den punkt
das was er damals gesagt hat das wird
immer wieder auch gesendet auch immer
wieder gezeigt dass die deutschen eben
über viele viele jahre
sehr eng verbunden waren und auch den
jetzigen pudding eben halt auch immer
geschmeichelt haben und eben halt
sich sich das nicht immer wieder bilder
die man eben halt das aufregend was half
von gesagt hat das ist nämlich das
angebot gab dass die deutschen
öleinfuhren aus russland komplett durch
einfuhren aus den usa ersetzt werden
können wenn das so ist und deutschland
geht nicht darauf ein ich gehe mal davon
aus dass das im wirtschaftsministerium
geprüft worden ist alle alternativen
bezugsquellen
das bestärkt mich das in meiner meinung
dass die deutsche politik dem land für
uns für die deutsch wenn wir aus amerika
soll ich sagen ist mir dass man momentan
ziemlich wurscht wir haben einen so
hohen steueranteil auf öl und gas traum
dir ist es egal wann ich ja das sag ich
ja wir haben ein so hohen steueranteil
dass man den entsprechend reduzieren
kann nein ich will ich will tut mir leid
das ist mir
der kampf gegen putin nicht selbst
portemonnaie das ist kann ich meine ja
leider urteilen dann muss man
entsprechend die mehrwertsteuer und die
und die mineralölsteuer senken
jedenfalls 40 weiter von putin abhängig
zu machen bestärkt mich in meiner
einschätzung dass man in berlin immer
noch daran denkt dass putin auf die eine
oder andere weise überleben wird
irgendeinen kompromiss frieden mit der
ukraine eingehen wird ein bisschen beute
macht in bestimmten teilen der ukraine
und man dann weiter mit ihm politik
machen muss und das finde ich empörend
weil mit putin finde ich geht gar nichts
mehr paul du kennst ja meine meinung ich
finde wir müssen sehr
genau dass
müller man hat aber auch gemerkt als ich
sie gerade auf die alltäglichen probleme
oder der wirtschaft angesprochen habe in
amerika kam auch gar nicht so
gravierende hervor wie ich ihn jetzt aus
deutschland berichten könnte die
deutsche wirtschaft trifft es auch
leider noch signifikanter als die
amerikanische ich würde aber gerne an
die frage an paul ronzheimer weitergeben
wie ist denn das wurde auch gerade
angesprochen die naivität der deutschen
zu erklären das hat herr müller gerade
auch angesprochen das ist ja schon lange
eigentlich klar war dass wir uns nicht
so abhängig machen sollten von putin wie
ist das zu erklären
na ja das sind glaube ich jetzt wieder
die fragen die in der vergangenheit sind
ja also was wurde seit 2004 10 falsch
gemacht kann ich viele dinge aufführen
die abhängigkeit von nord stream keine
wirklich scharfen sanktionen nach der
krim aktion genauso weitergehen dann in
der ost ukraine also putin hatte das
gefühl er kann machen und der westen
schaut zu macht ein bisschen was aber es
nicht so richtig ernst haben deswegen
hat ihn dass am ende mehr appetit
bereitet und hat dann dazu geführt dass
dieser große krieg entstanden ist und
ich stimme da uli umfänglich zu dass die
große gefahr besteht jetzt darin wir
haben über die verschiedenen pläne
friedenspläne gesprochen dass er wieder
einen trick anwendet und sagt ich will
ja verhandeln und dann nehme ich erst
mal diese gebiete und die ukraine wird
neutral und geht nicht in die nato und
dann kriegen wir das schon irgendwie hin
und der westen lässt sich anfangen
womöglich werden dann wieder einzelne
sanktionen sogar gelockert oder ein paar
monate später oder ein zwei jahre später
greift er wieder die ukraine komplett an
das ist ein szenario das wahrscheinlich
das wahrscheinlichste ist denn das hat
er bereits gezeigt unter anderem in
tschetschenien in den neunziger jahren
als man zunächst das land nicht erobern
konnte und es dann ein paar jahre später
wieder versucht hat und jetzt ziehen wir
auch wie er versucht syrische kämpfer zu
bekommen tschetschenische kämpfer zu
bekommen und sozusagen sein militär neu
aufzustellen und das ist das problem wie
geht man dann mit ihm um und das ist
eine große frage die nicht einfach zu
beantworten ist dann natürlich
sagen leute völlig zu recht ist muss
jetzt sofort frieden geben das dürfen
nicht mehr menschen sterben dem würde
ich sofort zustimmen nur die frage ist
dennoch gerade für die menschen hier zu
welchem preis die menschen sagen wir
wollen unser land verteidigen wir sind
bereit auch für unser land zu sterben
weil wir nicht wollen dass uns die
existenz abgesprochen wird und es ist
etwas existenzielles was hier passiert
von daher ist es nicht so leicht zu
beantworten ich war einmal die hand
ruhig werden wir noch mal einen punkt
machen zum thema auch gas und öl weil
das ist ja wirklich das was putin
treffen kann wir wissen russland
haushalt der speist sich vor allem aus
öl der speist sich vor allem aus gas der
speist sich vor allem aus dem verkauf
von rohstoffen und solange putin seine
rohstoffe noch nach europa und nach
deutschland verkaufen kann und ja
perverser weise auch noch von diesem
krieg profitiert denn derzeit steigen ja
die öl und gaspreise massiv wird putin
weiter sein kriegs treiben fortführen
können und deswegen bin ich da völlig
bei herrn jörges wir müssen den import
von öl wir müssen den import von gas aus
putin russland stoppen und gerade wenn
es alternativen gibt das was ich jetzt
von ralf müller gehört habe ist auch für
mich neu das müsste man in der tat dann
prüfen ist glaube ich auch ein wichtiger
als kreisauer
kreis will ich natürlich überprüfen aber
wir machen es uns auch zu einfach wenn
wir sagen wir führen nur sanktionen
durch die uns überhaupt nicht treffen
und die wir selber gar nicht merken und
das immer noch zb nord stream 1 läuft
und dass wir zwar gesagt haben naja nord
stream 2 geht nicht im betrieb aber nord
stream 1 läuft weiter dass die
bundesregierung da nicht reagiert hat
das finde ich ist ein skandal und
deswegen fordere ich auch das nord
stream 1 ebenso abgeschaltet wird und
dass man da wirklich die gasröhre zu
drehen dürfen nicht vergessen dass die
abhängigkeit von russland früher ja
genau umgekehrt betrachtet worden ist da
galt es als besonders sicher dass wir so
viel energie aus russland gegen weil die
russen sind ein verlässlicher lieferant
die haben ja schon als sowjetunion in
der geschichte über den ganzen krieg
hinweg im kalten krieg aber auch den
zweiten weltkrieg als er begann noch
geliefert
und insofern galt das als ein privileg
deutschlands seien aber dass ihn das ist
der große fehler der große denker das
haben ja das ist das weg dass viele
gedacht haben das jetzige russland ist
eine kleine sowjetunion und der
unterschied ist die frühere sowjetunion
wollte den status quo sichern das
jetzige russland ist nationalistisch und
möchte sich gebiete wie der öko bereich
wird zu sowjet führer wenn er
durchgeknallt gewesen wäre wie putin
nicht auch so was gemacht hätte
irgendwann wissen wir nicht aber
natürlich hat die partie ukraine zu
servette union gehört insofern gab es da
nichts zu erobern aber das ist auch der
grund dafür was sie erwähnt habe man hat
dass wir besonders
klug gehalten sich von russland abhängig
zu machen die liefern sehr viel zu
niedrigen preisen nena ja liefern zu
ganz günstigen preisen deshalb hat ja
auch hier werden in der presse berichtet
sarah
also was das angeht denke ich mal fast
die hälfte denke ich mal 40 prozent so
und die das ist auch der grund warum
angela merkel an dem projekt
festgehalten hat auch die hielt es ja
für ein ausweis deutscher klugheit sich
darauf einzulassen und sie glaubte die
kritik aus dem ausland haben nur mit
neid zu tun die sind alle nur neidisch
weil sie diese bevorzugte belieferung
nicht haben und nun sehen wir was daraus
geworden ist und
es ist von einem klumpenrisiko
entstanden ja also früher hatten wir
kernkraft da hatten wir dann auch kohle
da haben wir dann vielleicht die
erneuerbaren und gas und jetzt haben wir
gesagt raus aus kernkraft raus aus kohle
und dafür brauchen wir ganz viel
russisches gas und das ist ein
klumpenrisiko das würde kaum ein
unternehmer in der freien wirtschaft
eingehen ich glaube ich glaube auf jeden
fall nochmals wir haben und das haben
wir jetzt hier hab gerade jetzt gerade
auch in alaska gesagt sie könnten
besonders heißt also die regierung
unsere regierung müsste in kontakt mit
den amerikanern gehen soll hier ist mal
ganz einfach nein den kontakt mit ralf
in europa natürlich das ist es ja auch
das für eine milliarde pro tag bezahlen
wo solange wird dem gut ihm das geld
geben fördern wir natürlich auch
gleichzeitig den krieg wenn es aber
möglichkeiten gibt die jetzt gerade mit
amerika der ich doch noch bei andern
amerika hat die research auf jeden fall
für die bestimmte zeit uns zu helfen
dann bestehen da die möglichkeiten